please welcome my friends casey wilson
and june diane rafiel everybody
or did you just decide no we've
choreographed that and done that dance a
lot oh the dance yeah it did feel
planned and perfect it will work it was
we haven't had an entrance to use it for
yet yes but it's been in the works for
years now yeah that's an entrance down
that sort of prep show yeah when i was a
baby i was like we're gonna need this at
some point yeah like a baby dance yeah
are you saying we were dancing like
babies pretty much cause that's the kind
of dancing i'm into
dance like a baby
that's an old african proverb
do you feel free to dance on a dance
floor with
just abandon yeah
uh thank you for asking sure
i'll tell you as a tall fella
i feel like all eyes are on me yeah
regular sized people are here and then i
so i just i sit it out you ladies could
merge and blend into a swarm-like
situation we were just
we were talking about like i'm all i'm
just all upper body like my bottom
body's my my bottom body
what uh my lower half is not moving but
june will get very creative on a dance
floor and use the wall yeah i usually
take it to a wall and my dancing
just
anchor me yeah
no
that's true it's my dancing is not a
collaboration yes it's not i'm not into
partner dancing
i like to be on my own with the wall
with a wall preferably just an inanimate
object yeah just hands up feeling the
wall feeling myself
you know yeah it's there for you yeah
it's smooth it's different variants of
smoothness yes and i can count on it you
can count on it it's reliable what
happened to you that you dance with
walls
oh i'm not well
she's not i'm she's not i'm not doing
great she's not right
you